[Music]
we are going to have to come to the
interval reversal moment of forgiveness
in these next couple months years ahead
forgive the journey that we've taken and
stop with the typical activist
approaches
there's the bad guys cutting down the
rainforest there's the bad guys pumping
oil out there's the bad guys you know
doing chemical farming there's the bad
guys doing pharmaceutical medicine
whatever it is that doesn't work we have
to realize that's us being self-abusive
as a species that's that's not us moving
to the next thing the next expression of
our possibility
so we're gonna have to forgive
universally and move to this creative
moment as a species where we do
co-vision that radical future where we
simply behave differently it's time for
us to forgive the journey and realize we
have one moment to rebirth and in that
rebirth we can move into this creation
mode where we're no longer
stuck in that victim perpetrator
mentality